ازمه شركات التقنيه العالميه يا طاهر
تتصاعد مع تداعيات فيروس كورونا واتبعات
الاقتصاديه التي رافقتها يقول موقع
اتلانتيك ان شركات التكنولوجيا اصيبت
بالصدمه بسبب التضخم في فتره ما بعد
الجائحه جائحه كورونا وارتفاع اسعار
الفائده هذه الازمه فتحت الباب واسعا امام
التساؤل هل عصر الطفره التقنيه انتهى
وبدات شركات هذا القطاع بالانهيار بعض
اسهم شركات التكنولوجيا فقدت اكثر من 50%
من قيمتها السوقيه خلال الفتره الماضيه
وتكبدت خسائر قاسيه جعلت قيمتها السوقيه
تهوي الى ادنى مستوى خلال سنوات العشره
الماضيه الخسائر هذه دفعت عده شركات
لتسريحي نسب كبيره من موظفيها تجاوزت
المئات في بعض الاحيان وهو ما كان يبدو
امرا مستبعدا قبل السنوات تقرير اتلانتيك
الامريكي قال ان صناعه التكنولوجيا تواجه
ازمه منتصف العمر واشار الى زياده الكبيره
في عمليات التسليح الجماعي والفوضى التي
بدات تتكشف في شركه وتر مؤخرا والانهيار
المستمر للعملات المشفره وكلها امور حدثت
في اوقات متقاربه اضاف موقع اتلانتيك
المدراء التنفيذيين في اكبر شركات التقنيه
يقومون منذ سنوات بتحويل الموارد نحو
مشاريع جديده ذات عوائد غير مؤكده ضرب
الموقع مثلا على شركه امازون التي وظفت
مؤخرا اكثر من 10,000 شخص العملي على منتج
الذكاء الاصطناعي الخاص بها الاكثر يقول
التقرير ان الازمه تتبدى في اهتمام الماسك
بالسيارات والصواريخ اكثر من اهتمامه
بتوتر التي يقبع على راسها الخلاصه بحسب
الموقع عنا الفتره الحاليه هي ازمه منتصف
العمر لشركات التكنولوجيا البعض متفائلون
بانه قد تكون فتره استراحه بين العصور
التكنولوجيا قد تحدث بعدها طفره في برامج
الذكاء الاصطناعي او ربما يلوح امر اخر في
الافقي قريبا